hello and welcome to the US Trustee
ampionships here in st. Louis I'm
Jennifer Shehadeh and this is my Klein
and we have two rounds in the books and
we got off to an astonishing start with
Alexander Strickland ski making a
terrible blunder against one of the
pre-tournament favourites
Alexander ownership only shook had a
queen on g5 and sierpinski just played
d3 ownership could simply take the
bishop once he won with a check right
perhaps Alexander Stravinsky just forgot
that when his knight retreated to be one
that this rook was not guarding his
Bishop any more but just a terrible way
to start Alexander Ani Shooks a good
friend and really really felt bad for
his opponent to have to lose that way it
wasn't the shortest decisive game in US
Championship history that would be the
five move game by Kamran Shirazi in 1986
but at 11 moves it is not a great way to
start the championship for sure prince
key another thrilling contest Hikaru
Nakamura against Grand Master Robert has
definitely a crowd favorite Yale student
as well Nakamura chose the romantic
classical opening the Evans gambit and
he actually ended up winning a very nice
positional game
yeah Hess is behind the eight ball just
finishing his first year of college
studies at Yale said he didn't have as
much time as he'd like to prepare but
then he also said it wasn't an excuse
because even an unlimited amount of time
would not have led him to prepare for
the Evans gambit but it's Nakamura and
own Ashok who join a number of players
on one and a half out of two which also
includes defending champion gata Kamsky
for rusian Akopian
gregory Caetano and the young of
alexander Lenderman who's been playing
some very impressive chess so far in
fact he wanted gorgeous game in round
one against another youngster
grandmaster Ray Robson so one and a half
out of two that means no perfect scores
anymore which means that nobody is
eligible for that $64,000 juicy Fischer
bonus prize right not even 48 hours in
and the biggest prize in the mall is off
the table
nobody's been able to go 11 I know since
Fischer did almost half a century ago
and it's going to
least one more year until somebody does
now we do have a perfect score in the
u.s. Women's Championship defending
champion Isaac on ski playing her usual
smooth positional chess and we're gonna
expect a lot of wins from her that's
right she better get the wins and now
because looking ahead her final three
opponents will be rusev gold T on e Tata
have Abraham e'en and of course her
number-one rival Irina crush we had some
fantastic news break today the best game
prizes for the US Championship and US
Women's Championship will be judged by
arguably the best male and female chess
players of all time
Garry Kasparov and Judit Polgar have
signed on to judge each competition as
if there was enough pressure on the
players already with all you guys
watching at home if you're within
striking distance of the st. Louis Chess
Club coming out in person and also check
out the largest chess piece in the world
just certified by the Guinness Book of
World Records right across the street
from the Chess Club at the world chess
Hall of Fame and as always you can
follow along at 2:00 Eastern 1 central
on us chess gems calm
you